colas il était derrière la caméra c'est
dur de passer de bons et il a fait une
entrée excellente
j'ai envie de faire un petit et j'ai
envie de faire un petit conseil de
classe improvisée anormal meilleur c'est
guillaume genton elle veut pécho elle
aussi je suis même quand je suis pas
d'accord avec lui et ça arrive souvent
le trouve toujours pertinent étayé est
toujours calme et plus mauvaise élève
c'est bernard montiel mais vraiment sans
hésiter asus boules de la terre
n'importe quoi je sais pas quoi dire il
sort des mots qui sort de nulle part de
son cerveau est insupportable gym c'est
vraiment le plus nul vous savez pourquoi
parce que ça s'est mal passé tout à
l'heure en loge mais voulait mais quand
même
mais je les adore et vous avez vu un pur
pour les chroniqueurs le meilleur
chroniqueur séguier aux jantes way et le
moins bon c'est bernard outil qu'est ce
que moi je vais pas vous interroger sur
la voyante ça qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire à carla ce soir je voudrais bien
car leur show comme si tu es mon bébé
c'est sûrement ce qui va la vie depuis
qu'elle est partie de personnes tout
s'est écroulé autour de moi même à la
mort de bambi
parce que tu veux bien mais si tu vas
vis et camby synovate est de nouveau là
mais je voulais pas parce que parce que
tu vois j'ai je voulais pas t'embêter
pendant sept ans qu'on ne s'est pas vu
se dit la vérité car là c'est que tu as
vu que je buvais joue les j'applique
sinon voyais en train de voir si que
côté aaron pour moi et que tu as tout
supporter pour moi mais ça c'est toi on
te hais je le comme quand le gars là
raphaël moi c'est moi ce que je pense
j'espère que cette histoire sa tête a
pas mal pour un bien et que ça va vous
permettre de retrouver votre fille carla
que vous allez pouvoir vous retrouver
non mais la parole et je veux dire si
vous commencez par la victime
attendez vous à ce que je vous réponde à
ses principes du contradictoire monsieur
celle de ces deux messages
mais monsieur vous savez ravi d'avoir un
peu d'audience ici c'est vous faire et
vous fait plaisir
à la lumière des plateaux vous monte au
cerveau que je devais beaucoup plus
calme en coulisses que sur le plateau
n'est le site voici monsieur vous porte
pour vous qu'est ce qu'il a été robles
de sketches ici alors que on oublie tout
simplement que vivre avec le virus en ce
moment et bien c'est mourir avec le
virus lorsque vous parlant des
condamnations vous dites les comtés
menacés le vote par monsieur c'est là où
on a un problème vous et moi j'ai pas
parlé non attendez vous me parlez vous
n'avez aucun élément depuis tout à
l'heure sinon effectivement de dire ce
que vous pensez
moi je ne pense rien j'ai ce privilège
ne rien penser j'attends effectivement
vous me disiez que l'institut pasteur a
tort là où vous avez raison ou à la
tendance et le port de maillots avec
gérard piqué huit ans avait passé dans
le pas de calais ce week-end mais je
pense qu'il ya plein de choses qu'on
comprend pas honnêtement on est vraiment
des routes
il faut dire la reine et la réalité wen
et moi je pense qu'on pensait réellement
si on suit les modélisations quand on
écoute skis en bois de janvier que là on
serait dans la panade absolue et ce
serait la fin des haricots
j'espère qu'on sait tous et finalement
mieux les russes nous réservent de
nouvelles surprises et j'en ai une
question il aurait les yeux actionnaires
on va demander peut-être à gilles verdez
gilbert m oui m e division bonjour avait
amené un petit dossier traditionnel
vouliez des études mais voilà je vais
vous rigolez non mais je vais bien du
monde entier bien vous et cubeamd apam
et halévy bien aux études il n'y a pas
d'autres recours aux autres allez-y je
vous en filmant l'eau et calédonie mois
2 ans minimum idéalement appartiennent
en propre
alors je dis les mêmes qui valent ce
qu'ils valent qui sont soumis au débat
mais vous avec la semaine dernière les
élus par défaut sur ce point mais ya
rien eu mais monsieur est-ce que les
français peuvent connaître les études le
monsieur alors allons-y n'est pas les i
il n'ya pas votre truc déjà du film s
[Rires]
si vous voulez moi je ne voulais pas se
remettre et je ne suis pas allée
horrible cette dame dit des choses
épouvantables vraiment si je vous le dis
j'ai fait une est affectivement parce
qu'au bout d'un moment c'est quoi votre
jeu je comprends votre attitude que
souffrant d'un manque de notoriété vous
tentez de faire parler de vous à tout
prix y compris par des moyens illégaux
nous ne partageons pas du tout la même
philosophie à la moindre nouvelle injure
et à quelques moyens que ce soit je
porte je vais porter plainte
voilà donc la gtr vous menez avec moi je
peux finir donc j'ai aggravé à quoi
s'est mal fini bah non c'est une purge
de la paix et à la non mais ne vous
entendre dire c'est une purge
alors je vous supporte plus beau des le
support ventes et de recettes
je regrette je le regrette vingtaine
d'invités vraiment le cas
tout d'abord je tiens à reconnaître que
je me suis emporté dans votre émission
et que ce n'est pas ma façon d là
[Musique]
la voix d'abord je tiens à reconnaître
que je me suis emporté dans votre
émission et que ce n'est pas ma façon d
[Musique]